seven thousand one hundred and seventeen
okay it would be a short video if i just
gave that one answer
but that's the number according to the
2020 edition of ethnologue
widely considered to be the closest
thing we have to a directory of
languages
but here's the catch languages are not
separate distinct things they evolve
split merge fall out of use and it's
often difficult to say exactly where one
language ends and another begins
sure it's clear that my english and
another person's mandarin are
completely different languages but what
about my english and someone else's
scots or someone else's singlish or
someone else's rural southern american
english which
might not be understood by the the
dowager of downton abbey
and it's not just about location either
there's a difference between
the english i use here versus
what i actually use if i'm talking to
friends and what about over time
where does english start to become
middle english or old english
at some point it's different enough to
get a new label but
there isn't a naturally occurring clean
line
there's an old saying that a language is
just a dialect with an army and a navy
languages change to adapt to the needs
of their speakers and there are
a few reasons for that maybe it's to
provide
new words for new concepts computer
used to be the term for someone who was
paid to sit
and do calculations their job was to
compute they were
a computer when automated tools came
along they took on the name
sometimes languages changed to speed up
communication
going to wasn't always a marker for
future tense
and saying i'm going to start makes no
sense when taken literally you can't go
to
start start is not a place but the
phrase going to
became lexicalized and then it turned
into a word gonna and then i'm gonna
became i'm a that's a word in common use
that's probably under 50 years old still
english
sometimes a language changes because
people are trying to find an identity
the words we use help us fit in or to
stand out
language changes spread across
populations they act as markers of who
you are
and who your group is if enough people
change their pronunciation their
intonation their word and grammar
choices all together
you end up with a dialect if that
happens over and over and over and over
for centuries well
you might end up with a new language or
you might end up with an old one
falling out of use centuries of
colonialism and globalization have
encouraged the death of local languages
and even fairly major ones can be in
trouble icelandic is spoken by more than
000 people it's the national language of
a european country
but it's not supported by iphones or
android phones if you speak icelandic
and you want to use a smartphone
so if you want to participate in modern
life you need to speak another language
probably english very little media is
translated into icelandic almost no one
who moves to iceland speaks it which
means that
icelandic youth sometimes just use
english between each other as a first
language unless deliberate efforts are
made to keep it alive
even a national language like icelandic
could be at risk eventually
so yes ethnologue counts 7000 languages
based on
fairly reasonable lines that they've
decided on someone has to draw some
lines somewhere
so they do but of those 7050 to 90
of them may well be functionally extinct
by the end of the century
and while i'm sure there would be
advantages to one global language
it's not just about communication it's
about access to culture to history to
subtext to the insights
that can come from one language
explaining a single
word what would take another language 50
if you're watching this and thinking
doesn't matter too much
imagine how you'd feel if it was english
that was endangered and ask yourself
if you'd be okay with the next
generations only having translations
of the works that you grew up with if
you want more linguistics then my
co-author gresham mcculloch has a
podcast called
enthusiasm the link is in the
description and i recommend it
you